bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat poursuivre dans un
instant une audition qui s'est tenue
hier après midi au sénat
l'audition de ségolène royal la ministre
de l'ecologie qu'a été entendu par les
sénateurs de la commission d' enquête
sur le coût économique et financier de
la pollution de l'air
cette commission d'enquêté a été mise en
place au mois de février dernier et
depuis les sénateurs ont multiplié les
déplacements mais aussi les auditions de
chercheurs d'os ong d'acteurs publics ou
encore d'entreprises concernées par ce
sujet hier c'était donc au tour de la
ministre d'être entendu la ministre qui
a présenté sa vision de l'écologie une
vision résolument optimiste positive et
non pas punitive de l'écologie ségolène
royal qui a également expliqué les
grands axes de son plan pour la qualité
de l'air avec notamment le grand retour
de la pastille verte
vous allez le voir les échanges ont
parfois été assez vif avec les sénateurs
notamment avec la rapporteure
écologistes de cette commission denquête
la sénatrice leïla et chez tout de suite
donc retour à la salle clemenceau
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
vous remercie de vous être engagé sur
cette commission d' enquête relative au
coût économique et financier de la
pollution de l'air parce que c'est un
sujet de santé publique majeur c'est
aussi un enjeu social car ce sont les
populations les plus fragiles qui sont
exposées une mauvaise qualité de l'air
les coûts sanitaires de la pollution
sont estimées entre 20 et 30 milliards
d'euros par an selon l'étude de 2012
publié par mon ministère commissariat
général du développement durable les
ccoo sont essentiellement liés la
mortalité
il faut y ajouter le coût du à
l'inconfort à l'inquiétude à la
souffrance du fait d'être malade
sur ces 20 à 30 milliards 1,2 milliards
pourraient être directement économisés
chaque année pour le système de soins
par des mesures simples plusieurs
dizaines de millions d'habitants en
france sont exposés à une mauvaise
qualité de l'air dans certaines zones du
territoire et particulièrement dans les
zones urbaines à
forte densité la france vient de
recevoir un avis motivé de la commission
européenne pour non respect des valeurs
sanitaires pour les particules pm10 dit
lawn sont visés marseille toulon paris
douai béthune valenciennes grenoble lyon
nice la martinique et quelques zones
urbaines en région rhône alpes et paca
nous allons très prochainement répondre
à cet avis motivé en faisant état des
actions engagées des résultats obtenus
qui conduisent déjà à considérer que le
nombre de zones en déplacement c'est
probablement réduit je vais revenir dans
quelques instants
des nouvelles actions engagées et bien
évidemment je pense que les travaux de
votre commission denquête qui
s'inscrivent dans cette actualité
brûlante de la demande de la commission
européenne pourrait fort utilement aussi
être transmis comme élément d'appui aux
politiques gouvernementales qui
tiendrait compte de vos recommandations
que le gouvernement pourrait reprendre à
son compte et communiqué en complément à
la commission européenne
c'est dire l'importance de vos auditions
et de vos propositions auxquelles je
serai particulièrement vigilant parce
que je le répète cela pourra nous aider
à répondre à cet avis motivé de la
commission européenne des dépassements
de valeurs sanitaires pour le dioxyde
d'azoté concerne également une quinzaine
de territoires en france la commission a
engagé le 13 février 2014 une produit
une procédure heureux union européenne
pilotes
la commission a clôturé la procédure et
la france vient de recevoir la mise en
demeure pour 19 zones là aussi les
actions engagées doivent être
communiqués à la commission
dans ce contexte la participation de
tous les acteurs est indispensable
d'abord pour réduire de manière pérenne
les concentrations de polluants dans
l'atmosphère en agissant sur le
transport sur l'industrie sur
l'agriculture sur les constructions pour
éviter les pics et le dépassement
récurrent des seuils réglementaires
notamment lorsque les conditions
météorologiques les favorise
troisièmement pour informer les français
des risques et des sources de pollution
et protéger leur santé et les inciter
aussi à agir chaque fois qu'ils le
peuvent
le bilan national de la qualité de l'air
qui sera publié par le ministère en
septembre montrera qu en 2014 la
situation s'est améliorée qui est la
preuve que l'action collective est
payante pour les particules pm10 seule
une agglomération de plus de 250000
habitants a dépassé les seuils
réglementaires contre 5 en 2013
pour le dioxyde d'azoté très
agglomérations de plus de 250 mille
habitants n'ont pas respecté le seuil de
concentration contre 15 en 2013 petite
amélioration passe de 13 à 15 mais il
reste donc beaucoup par entreprendre et
j'ai engagé pour ma part des actions qui
ont été remises en perspective devant le
conseil national de l'ère du 2 juin
dernier et donc on appuie bien sûr sous
toutes les propositions des forces vives
et des actions notamment qui sont prises
par les élus locaux parce que c'est
essentiellement dans les agglomérations
quand on a besoin que les forces vives
des agglomérations prennent leur
responsabilité premièrement la création
du certificat qualité de l'air auxquels
je m'étais engagé devant la conférence
environnementale a été mise au point il
va être expérimenté va donner un
avantage aux véhicules les moins
polluants
cette classification va s'appuyer sur
les émissions polluantes des voitures
particulières des deux roues des poids
lourds des autobus et comportera sept
classes en fonction de la motorisation
et de l'âge du véhicule une cas
spécifiques réservées aux véhicules
électriques zéro émission une dérogation
sera accordé aux véhicules
d'intervention et d'urgence cette
échelle de classement va permettre aux
collectivités notamment aux maires des
grandes agglomérations président
l'agglomération de moduler finement les
mesures incitatives ou restrictive que
ces collectivités souhaitent mettre en
place en concertation avec les habitants
et les acteurs économiques du territoire
elles pourront par exemple et je fais
référence à la loi de transition
énergétique pour la croissance verte
créer des zones à circulation restreinte
qui sont prévus dans la loi dans la
partie transports propres que les
sénateurs et sénatrices ici présentes
connaissent bien pour y avoir
abondamment participer ces zones à
circulation restreinte pour la qualité
de l'air seront réservés à certaines
classes de véhicules toute l'année où
certains jours de la semaine pour
diminuer drastiquement la pollution
deuxièmement proposer certains avantages
de stationnement de voies de circulation
seuls véhicules écrit qu'aux véhicules
plus faiblement émetteurs pour
encourager l'usagé je souhaite que ce
dispositif soit simple et lisible pour
les usagers comme pour les agents
chargés du contrôle et limite les
risques de fraudes afin de rendre
efficaces les mesures qui seront mises
en place à l'appui cette identification
donc ce certificat a été élaboré des néo
videmment avec le ministre de
l'intérieur puisque bien évidemment pour
les contrôles il faut coller et
certificats soit lisible
il sera délivré par voie postale à titre
individuel à chaque propriétaire de
véhicule qui en fera la demande sur
internet
il est mise en place au 1er janvier 2016
des expérimentations seront lancés dès
l'automne le coût du certificat sur un
maximum de 5 euros bref c'est une
démarche à la fois pédagogique nullement
porteuse d'exclusion puisque les
entreprises pourront être amenés à
s'interroger sur l'offre de mobilité
qu'elles peuvent proposer à leurs
salariés
les usagers seront responsabilisés sur
leur contribution à la qualité de l'air
les élus disposeront d'un nouveau moyen
d'action des constructeurs automobiles
les industriels seront incités à innover
et mettre sur le marché des transports
propres
les pouvoirs publics pourront adapter
les mesures d'urgence en cas de pic de
pollution en interdisant la circulation
véhicules les plus polluants et pas
seulement avec un système père un père
qui n'a aucun sens en termes de mesure
de la pollution même si ça réduit ce
simplement en volume la circulation mais
ça ne cible pas sur les véhicules les
plus polluants
alors j'ai entendu effectivement un
certain nombre de réactions notamment de
la part des foyers qui n'ont pas les
moyens de se racheter une voiture moins
polluante
je précise donc le gouvernement mis en
place une prime de 10 mille euros cette
année pour inciter à l'achat de
véhicules électriques a étendu ses
primes aussi aux véhicules propres
d'occasion ce qui était une forte
demande dans la prime est bien sûr
inférieur
et l'idée c'est inciter aussi les
constructeurs à mettre sur le marché des
véhicules avec des ventes mensualisés
pour permettre aussi à toutes les touts
les tout les niveaux de rémunérer mieux
accéder
j'ajoute aussi que ne voulant pas d'
écologie punitive
ce certificat est facultatif et me dise
pourquoi facultatif avec ce soit
obligatoire etc
il est facultatif parce que du coup
seules les voitures propres ont demandé
certificat dont vont bénéficier des
avantages et la stigmatisation qui était
craint effectivement par les certificats
sur les voitures les plus polluantes
aller vite il n'a pas besoin d'exister
puisque les gens qui ont des voitures
crypte hollande ont pas intérêt avec le
certificat sur leur pare-brise
en revanche ils ne pourront pas
bénéficier des avantages liés aux
véhicules propres
donc on est dans un an dans une
dynamique positive qui permet
effectivement de ne pas stigmatiser
c'était une petite crainte que j'ai vu
surgir sur l'internet où les gens qui
avaient des voitures polluantes et venez
on va pouvoir rouler avec un certificat
qui va nous stigmatiser de couleur
sombre parce que pour l'instant on n'a
pas les moyens de changer de voiture
donc voilà il faut prendre en
considération tous ses aspects pour que
vraiment on s'inscrit dans des
dynamiques positives et que ce soit
surtout les constructeurs qui engage les
entreprises qui fasse vraiment des plans
de mobilité comme c'est prévu dans la
loi de transition énergétique les
collectivités des readers qui et
développe les transports propres ou les
transports de substitution propre quand
il ya des pics de pollution et c'est
cette dynamique là qu en second lieu
donc les certificats ensuite j'ai lancé
l'appel à projets ville respirable en
cinq ans pour mobiliser les
collectivités et tester les solutions
innovantes
le cahier des charges a été rendue
publique les collectivités
effectivement agglomération joue un rôle
essentiel dans la lutte contre la
pollution de l'air elles ont des
compétences pour agir concrètement cet
appel à projets va permettre
d'expérimenter des mesures radicales
pour la qualité de l'air afin de faire
baisser sensiblement la pollution et
vont bénéficier d'une aide financière
pouvant aller jusqu'à un million d'euros
par lauréat pour déployés localement les
dispositifs du projet de loi de
transition énergétique et notamment
définir rapidement des zones à
circulation restreinte engager
rapidement le renouvellement des flottes
publiques 10 autobus et des taxis parce
que les gens ne comprennent pas pourquoi
on leur demande de rouler propre
lorsqu'il voit des bus ou des taxis
polluants ensuite mettre en place les
prime de conversion y compris pour les
deux roues et les utilitaires développer
la mobilité électrique à quel
déploiement notamment des bornes de
recharge de façon accélérée inciter
toutes les entreprises à avoir des plans
de circulation multiplié les incitations
au covoiturage et enfin engager les
déplacements en deux-roues mettre en
place ensuite avec les professionnels
concernés des mesures de lutte contre la
pollution dans les transports publics et
le ministère a engagé des discussions
avec les compagnies d'autobus pour
mettre en place des plans d'élimination
des diesel les plus polluants dans
l'industrie nous avons lancé des audits
et des programmes d'action notamment
dans les pme
ensuite dans l'activité agricole qui est
une source de pollution importante qui
est taboue mais je pense qu'il faut
avoir le courage de le dire parce que
c'est aussi l'intérêt des agriculteurs
qu'on puisse identifier ses sources de
pollution les nommer et c'est aussi
d'une question de leur propre santé qui
est en jeu et je crois que les choses
commencent à évoluer de façon très
positive il ya le problème des produits
d'épandage qui dispersent des polluants
dans l'air et donc là aussi il est
parfaitement possible de de même que
j'aie interdite vous le savez les
épandages aériens
je pense que les pulvérisations qui ont
lorsqu on observait les pics de
pollution à paris joue un rôle très
important dans le pic de lipides de
pollution et notamment malheureusement
les épandages aériens du centre de
l'europe
y a pas de frontières pour la pollution
qui a été rabattu sur le nord de la
et sur l'est il faut donc engager des
techniques qu'ils arrêtent déjà en
france et puis peut-être mener la
bataille au niveau européen pour arrêter
les les épandages par pulvérisation qui
contribuent gravement à la pollution de
l'air dans la construction la rénovation
thermique des logements les
constructions énergie positive
les filtres à particules pour le
chauffage au bois le remplacement des
appareils de chauffage anciens sont
également mouvement et dans les appels à
projets sur les villes respirable grax
et ville met en place des actions
d'information des citoyens parce qu'on
est à la fois dans l'application de la
loi de transition énergétique pour la
performance énergétique des bâtiments
la mise en place du crédit d'impôt sur
la transition énergétique qui permet à
tous les particuliers de changer leur
appareil de chauffage anciens polluants
en appareils de chauffage plus
performant ou compris pour le chauffage
au bois et puis les bâtiments à énergie
positive sont des bâtiments justement il
n'y a plus de pollution atmosphérique
les projets donc ces projets de villes
respirable en cinq ans et tous toutes
ces actions ne sont pas réservées aux
lauréats de l'appel à projets ville
respire à la bien évidemment l'idée
c'est de montrer comment on peut
concentrer accéléré et avec une
impulsion plus forte
la mutation de la civilisation urbaine
finalement seront réservés aux
agglomérations situées dans l'une des 36
zones couvertes par un plan de
protection de l'atmosphère à prouver ou
en projet la date limite de dépôt des
dossiers est fixée au 5 septembre pour y
annonce des lauréats le 25 septembre
lors de la journée nationale de la
qualité de l'air ça paraît long en fait
les très courts parce que ça veut dire
que sur tous les aspects des sources de
pollution
il va falloir apporter des projets
structurés qui souvent sont déjà en
gestation mais ça ça va permettre de les
accélérer
les lauréats bénéficieront d'un appui
financier méthodologique les aides de
l'ademe le financement du fonds de la
transition énergétique et le programme
des investissements d'avenir pour les
actions agricoles
les financements du ministère seront
mobilisés notamment le plan ecophyto qui
bénéficie aussi de fonds importants qui
pourront être concentrés sur les projets
intégrés
en troisième lieu donc les certificats
les l'appel à projets ville respirable
en cinq ans troisièmement les aides
financières en faveur de la qualité de
l'air comme cela a été annoncé par le
gouvernement lors de la conférence
environnementale il faut rééquilibrer
progressivement la fiscalité entre les
différentes sources de décence enfin
entre le diesel et l'essence pour être
clair en prenant en compte les impacts
écologiques pour les entreprises et les
citoyens donc le bonus automobile et le
nouveau bonus portent déjà leurs fruits
pour aider à diffuser de véhicules
propres au premier trimestre de l'année
je parle du bonus de 10000 euros on
constate une progression de 89% en un an
des ventes de véhicules électriques
enfin on parle de banos 89 on se fait
plaisir ça fait beaucoup mais quand même
il n'y a pas raison de ne pas le dire
2903 voitures particulières exactement
électriques ont été immatriculés au
premier trimestre contre 1500 le
trimestre précédent
mais il faut bien commencer bon donc
selon les constructeurs les commandes de
véhicules électriques qui sont déjà en
forte hausse en avril avec des volumes
quatre à huit fois supérieurs à ceux
constatés en avril 2014
les derniers chiffres connus de vente en
mai confirme la tendance
mais bien évidemment on sait très bien
ce qu'il faudrait pour déclencher ses
achats c'est le déploiement des bornes
électriques kit également en cours
puisque dans un programme
d'investissements d'avenir
il ya le déploiement des bornes
électriques d'un côté et d'autre part
bien évidemment c'est l'autonomie
l'autonomie qui régresse encore le point
d'interrogation et en même temps on
observe que quand des entreprises ou des
particuliers ont fait le choix de
véhicules électriques ils peuvent pas
revenir en arrière tellement le le
progrès qualitatifs et financier est
considérable et dans une des solutions
sans doute serait de déployer des
flottes électrique dans les entreprises
avec des systèmes d loquace de location
salariés il ya aussi le covoiturage
pense de véhicules électriques et qui
pourraient être intéressants et le
déploiement des deux roues électriques
le parlement je le rappelle d'ailleurs a
souhaité inscrire dans la loi relative à
la transition énergétique plusieurs
dispositions encourager les salariés à
utiliser leur vélo
l'indemnité kilométrique vélo la
déduction d'impôt pour les sociétés qui
mettent à disposition de leurs salariés
des flottes de bicyclette dans le
secteur des transports ces mesures
viendront en complément de l'engagement
de l'état et des collectivités locales à
qui la loi pour la transition
énergétique demandera de renouveler des
véhicules propres par leur flotte de
véhicules dont celles de bus et de cars
je précise aussi que dans la transition
énergétique les collectivités locales
doivent obligatoirement lorsqu'ils
remplacent des véhicules des flottes
administrative obligatoirement acheter
un véhicule sur deux qui est un véhicule
propre ou électriques
quatrièmement il faut vraiment mobilisé
la profession agricole sur la qualité de
l'air
d'abord parce que je le rappelle c'est
pas les agriculteurs puis qui polluent
les autres c'est les activités agricoles
qui subissent aussi eu elle-même les
dégâts causés par la pollution de l'air
les rendements agricoles peuvent
notamment être impactés par les épisodes
de pollution les baisses de rendement
peuvent aller jusqu'à 20% sur le blé
quand pendant les périodes
de fortes concentrations en ozone mais
certaines pratiques agricoles contribue
également pollution de l'atmosphère je
les dis la diminution des émissions co2
pour lui agricole est indispensable elle
rejoint d'ailleurs la problématique de
de relance des pollinisateurs et de
lutte contre la mortalité des abeilles
des pollinisateurs qui est aussi un
fléau pour l'agriculture et notamment
sur les épisodes de pollution printanier
qui est vraiment un sujet à prendre en
considération en tant que tel et vous
avez vu que les pics de pollution dont a
parlé récemment ce sont les pollutions
au printemps parce que là on a toute la
concentration d'à la fois une
augmentation de la température de l'air
donc la pollution automobile qui
s'accentue et on a bien sûr les
épandages agricoles qui viennent
renforcer la pollution de l'air par les
transports et donc il ya une forte
contribution de l'ammoniaque dans la
formation des particules au même titre
que les émissions liées au trafic des
nouveaux financements sont mises en
place pour expérimenter avec le soutien
du ministère de l'agriculture et de
l'ademe des pratiques plus performante
une enveloppe de 20 millions d'euros sur
cinq ans est dédié à ce programme il ya
donc les moyens financiers il faut
maintenant les cibler et les orienter
vers des actions efficaces
une table ronde avec la profession
agricole sur la qualité de l'air est en
cours d'organisation pour examiner
quelles solutions s'offrent aux
exploitants à la proche de la période
d'hiver aussi plus propice aux épisodes
de pollution dans quelques alpiq de
printemps et ensuite y est le pic de
entré dans l'hiver
cinquièmement je souhaite améliorer le
dispositif de gestion des épisodes de
pollution et vous vous souvenez que les
polémiques au mois de mars dernier
et donc j'ai mandaté avec les ministres
en charge de l'intérieur et de la santé
une mission d'inspection sur la gestion
des épisodes de pollution pour disposer
des recommandations pour faire face aux
prochaines crises
cette mission a présenté ses réflexions
du devant le conseil national de l'air
début juin et va rendre son rapport très
prochainement sixièmement je souhaite
développer la surveillance des polluants
non réglementées pour avoir une approche
dynamique une campagne nationale
exploratoire de surveillance des
pesticides a été lancée comme décidé
dans le cadre de
de route de la dernière conférence
environnementale elle va s'appuyer sur
les recommandations de landes cesse sur
le protocole harmonisé de surveillance
qui a été établi par le laboratoire
central de surveillance de la qualité de
l'air et mis en oeuvre par les
associations agréées de surveillance de
la qualité de l'air l'ansès est en cours
de saisine aussi pour les autres
polluants non réglementée
car il convient d'être vigilant dans les
années qui viennent
une journée nationale de la qualité de
l'air est prévu le 25 septembre
aussi pour mobiliser tous les français
donc intéressant qu'à ce moment là en
plus déployés les actions et les
recommandations qui seront les vôtres
enfin il ya toutes les actions aussi de
mesure de la qualité de l'air dans les
établissements qui reçoivent du public
c'est en particulier dans les écoles
j'avais été saisi par les maires pour
essayer de des plus pragmatiques sur la
question de la mesure dans chaque pièce
de chaque crèche de chaque école
maternelle chaque collège et de chaque
salle de lycée je m'en suis rendu compte
en tant que présidente de région passe
quand j'ai vu inscrire le but d'y jeter
pour le calcul le contrôle de la qualité
de l'air mais comment est-ce que les
collectivités vont payer une charge et
donc gg assouplit le texte réglementaire
et j'ai fait mettre au point par le
qu'elle organise t mis au point le un
kit l'ineris qui a mis au point un kit
de mesure de l'air ce qui fait que les
employés municipaux peuvent procéder
eux-mêmes aux mesures de qualité de
l'air dans leurs équipements municipaux
les départements dans les collèges des
régions dans les lycées sans avoir
recours à des cabinets privés très très
coûteux en revanche s'ils veulent un
approfondissement dan d'une indication
donnée par des kits d'auto contrôle de
la qualité de l'air bien évidemment ils
peuvent procéder à des analyses
complémentaires
voilà il y aura encore certainement
beaucoup de choses à dire et j'imagine
que vous avez des questions quels sont
les éléments monsieur le président la
rapporteure mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs que je tenais à porter à votre
connaissance un temps bien évidemment
comme je vous dis très attentive et très
demandeuse des propositions que vous
ferez car je le répète
nous sommes dans un contentieux européen
et moi je le vois de façon positive est
tant mieux on a un contentieux européen
donc moi j'ai engagé mon ministère qui
s'ouvre on est dans une position
défensive et on essaye de trouver les
arguments pour contester la mise en
demeure de européenne
et bien moi je pense qu'il faut faire
tout le contraire et saisir les
occasions de ces mises en demeure
européenne eba pour être à la hauteur
et puis pour changer de modèle pour
faire en sorte que d'un problème nous
fassions une solution et même un élément
de progrès et d'anticipation merci
beaucoup madame la ministre je note avec
satisfaction et plaisir le bonheur qui
est le vôtre de connaître du contentieux
pour sortir pour sortir à la fois avec
envie avec le sourire surtout et comme
le sourire est sur ma voisine madame la
rapporteure je ne résiste
évidemment pas plus longtemps à la joie
de lui passer la parole je nous
appellent simplement à l'issue des
questions de madame la rapporteure à de
la concision chers collègues lorsque
chacun de nous aura la parole je vous
vois déjà nombreux et gourmand pour le
questionnement simplement nous notre
camp notre temps comme celui de madame
la ministre également compté et je vais
pendant que madame la rapporte poser
question je vais prendre voilà les
doigts qui se lève il n'y a aucun souci
personne ne sera oublié
m dames ministre merci de votre exposé
je vais vous poser avec un certain
nombre de questions extrêmement courte
si on pourrait également avoir des
réponses courtes et consiste pour que
l'ensemble de mes collègues puissent
également posé un certain nombre de
questions depuis 1983 et les premières
études de l' oms nous avons la certitude
que la pollution de l'air a un impact
sanitaire et notamment
le désert ces derniers sont responsables
de plus de 50 mille décès prématuré en
france chaque année de l'apparition de
l'aggravation de nombreuses maladies
telles que des cancers du poumon ou
encore de la vessie des maladies
cardiovasculaires des maladies
respiratoires de nombreuses allergies de
l'apparition d'irritation oculaire et
d'inflammation des muqueuses c'est
également un facteur d'accroissement des
problèmes de fertilité de risque de
malformations congénitales et de
mortalité infantile de facteurs
d'affaiblissement du système immunitaire
de facteurs d'augmentation des taux
d'hospitalisation et des études
extrêmement sérieuse des mondes
désormais un lien entre la pollution de
l'air et la maladie de parkinson voir la
maladie d'alzheimer et très récemment il
vient d'être démontré un lien qui entre
la pollution de l'air et l'obésité
madame la ministre est ce que le
ministère de l'écologie a réalisé des
études sur le coût économique et
financier de la pollution de l'air si
oui quel est son périmètre la durée et
le nombre de polluants qui ont fait
l'objet de deux sets de cette analyse
avez vous également étudié les effets
cocktails
madame la ministre pouvait vous
également nous donner si vous en avez
une idée
la date de l'arrêt du diesel je me
permettrai également d'observer je salue
votre votre acharnement et la luttre
puisque vous avez précisé à maintes
reprise votre intention de lutter de
manière énergique et déterminé contre la
pollution de l'air nous sommes tous
conscients qu'il faut agir en ce sens et
pour autant vous avez supprimé l'écotaxe
vous avait réintroduit l'autorisation
des feux de cheminée et vous avez
parallèlement renier sur l'abandon
puisque vous avez abandonné la loi de
diesel est ce que vous ne pensez pas
qu'il ya une forme d'incohérence si je
puis dire entre le le propos affichés
qui qui fait qu'en fait vous souhaitez
aller dans le sens de la dépollution de
l'air et pour autant vous prenez des
mesures qui ne sommes pas en adéquation
avec les objectifs que vous avez voulu
fixer la semaine dernière assez
justement vous avez annoncé votre
volonté d'interdire la commercialisation
du round up dans les jardineries à titre
totalement personnelle jeu j'adhère
complètement 7 à ces deux positions pour
autant est-ce que cette mesure n'est pas
suffisante puisque comme vous le savez
l'impact sanitaire des pesticides et
notamment des particuliers
l'usa parlant et dont l'usagé par des
particuliers ne représentent qu'à 5 à
10% est ce que ce n'est pas une mesure
infime compte tenu de l'impact global et
je finirai sur deux dernières
interrogations madame la ministre
à partir de quel seuil vous considérez
que la pollution de l'air grève de
manière significative en de manière
significative nos comptes publics
est-ce qu'il est patent de d'agir de
manière efficace est ce que c'est un
seuil à partir de 10 milliards de 20
milliards de 40 milliards 60 ou 100
milliards et enfin je finirai ne croyez
vous pas que le principe de
pollueur-payeur s'est plutôt transformée
aujourd'hui en consommateurs
contribuables paient vous remercie
madame la ministre je vous propose voilà
bien sûr même l'a rapporté oui merci
pour ces nombreuses questions je pense
que vous avez voit même parfaitement
décrit les dégâts sanitaires de la
pollution de l'air en reprenant
effectivement là
la liste de toutes les atteintes à la
santé sous toutes ses formes
comme je le disais tout à l'heure en
2012 commissariat général au
développement durable a estimé le coût
de la pollution de l'air pour la société
entre 20 et 30 milliards d'euros par an
c'est à la fois le coût sanitaire le
coût social aussi le coût économique et
je me fera plaisir de vous transmettre
le détail de cette étude en tout cas qui
rejoint tout à fait l'évaluation selon
laquelle il ya là à la fois un enjeu de
santé publique mais aussi un enjeu
économique est ce que parce qu'ils me
sentant pas d'ami e s que sur ce coup et
économiques de la pollution de l'air
vous avez identifié les effets cocktail
est ce que les conséquences des effets
cocktails sont intégrées dans le calcul
que vous donnez à hauteur de 20 à 30
milliards d'euros
écoutez à ce stade je pense que ce que
c'est intégrer mais je n'ai pas ici
entre les mains la totalité du du
rapport dans sa dent dans sa complexité
il ya la fois
les impacts sur la santé liés à la
pollution de l'air à la morbidité les
dépenses de traitement d'examen de
consultations médicales
et puis les interactions sur ce que vous
dites par l'effet cocktail les
interactions entre c'est ça que vous
voulez dire les interactions entre danse
est pour préciser mon interrogation d'un
ministre nous avons auditionné un un
certain nombre de scientifiques qui
justement précisait nous expliquait en
fait que sur les études qui ont été
faites les coûts sont nécessairement un
minima puisqu'il simplement on a des
analyses sur l'impact sanitaire
grosso modo sur 6 à 20 maximum poliment
et que les effets cocktails sont
absolument jamais abordé donc si vous
avez une autre étude ceci nous
intéressera parce que ça rentrera en
contradiction avec les différentes
analyses qu'on a pu avoir et oui je
connaissais je pense que ces faits ne
sont pas intégrés dans des effets
cocktails ne sont pas intéressants je ne
crois pas non parce que c'était vraiment
les effets mais ce qu'on peut faire à ce
moment là suite à votre observation
c'est comme la saisine de l'endss s est
en cours
on pourrait explicitement précisé
la commande relatif aux effets cocktails
parce que je pense que nous n'y avons
pas pensé voilà oui l'intérêt aussi de
ses auditions ça permet de d'enrichir
les travaux et les démarches ensuite sur
l'écotaxe l'écotaxe n'a pas été supprimé
puisque vous le savez qu'à la place du
système complexe qui je veux pas revenir
sur eux sur ce sujet là mais qui
entraînait quand même une déperdition de
25 % des taxes payées par les français
au profit d'une rémunération d'un
service rendu
la part des parrains les entreprises
privées nous avons préféré la taxe de 2
centimes sur le gasoil qui a été
appliquée donc cette taxe a été
appliquée elle a été appliquée si à
hauteur de 4 centimes sur les camions et
donc l'écotaxe cesson écotaxe donc
l'écotaxe a été au contraire simplifier
avec une rentabilité immédiat sur la
question des feux de cheminée je pense
en effet que la façon de l'interdît tel
qui est généralisé tel qu'il avait été
prononcée mélanger allègrement
l'interdiction des chauffages au bois
qui sont sources de pollution par
particules bien différent surtout les
vieux chauffage qui ne sont pas aux
normes
avec les flambées de bois de loisirs
moment de l'hiver et donc interdire à la
veille de noël les feux de cheminée
c'est pour moi de l'écologie punitive et
c'est pour ça que j'ai arrêté c'est ai
je demandé la réforme de cet arrêté pour
bien cerner les choses
les choses sont aujourd'hui cerné c'est
à dire que nous avons à la fois mis en
place là aussi dans une logique
d'écologie positive
le crédit d'impôt qui va permettre aux
particuliers de changer leurs vieilles
chaudières à bois éventuellement
polluantes par des chaudières à bois
avec des filtres à particules donc c'est
très important justement que dans les
territoires les gens soient informés de
ces possibilités de changement
deuxièmement on a encouragé la mise au
point d'un système très innovant sur des
filtres à particules qui peuvent
s'installer aussi sur les foyers
ouvertes ça c'est les flambées à foyer
ouvert
troisièmement dans le crédit d'impôt les
inserts c'est à dire des foyers qui sont
beaucoup moins polluants sont égales
bénéficie également du crédit d'impôt et
enfin je ne souhaite pas que par une
interdiction de généraliser et non non
adaptée du chauffage au bois on puisse
porter atteinte brutalement parce qu'on
connaissait l'impact des annonces à
toute la filière bois de chauffage
parce que c'étaient des annonces aussi
dramatiques sur la filière bois de
chauffage qui tout d'un coup se trouvait
ainsi stigmatisés et comme on mélange un
peu tout compte y aller comme ça des
informations brutes de décoffrage
effectivement c'était une mauvais signal
qui était donnée puisque parallèlement
beaucoup de collectivités développe les
plates formes de récupération le
chauffage bois l'utilisation de la
biomasse etc qui reste une des filières
de développement des énergies
renouvelables auxquelles je tiens tout
particulièrement et que je veux
absolument développer notamment en
milieu rural
sur la question du round up en effet
dans un premier temps donc le rendent la
vente aux particuliers est interdite en
vente directe et doit être accompagnée
d'un
conseil ce sera effectif au 1er janvier
et je me réjouis de voir que non
seulement la réseau des jardineries dans
laquelle je me suis rendu à accepter
dans un partenariat positif de le mettre
en place avant même toute obligation et
ça c'est vraiment je pense une bonne
logique de progresser dans le domaine
écologique c'est-à-dire que les
partenaires économiques de même se
rendre compte qu'il ya des solutions et
deuxièmement suite à cette action
les chaînes de distribution de grande
distribution qui nous excepte impossible
viennent de me contacter pour me dire
qu'elles vont également mettre en place
carrefour pour ne pas le citer ça c'est
vraiment beaucoup de 2,1 énorme tonnage
de vente de pesticides mise en place de
glyphosate et donc vous voyez quelques
choses peuvent évoluer très vite dès
lors qu'on incite les partenaires à
rentrer dans des logiques partenariale
mais rassurez vous ça ne va pas diminuer
leur chiffre d'affaires puisque l ont
bien compris que il y avait une montée
en puissance aussi des produits de
substitution naturel la limite tant
mieux et par conséquent c'est vraiment
la démonstration qu'une évolution aussi
de de l'industrie des productions et des
formes de vente et de service rendu aux
consommateurs peuvent être efficaces dès
lors qu'on leur dit si toute façon si
vous ne le faites pas il y aura un
moment une obligation ou vous avez
intérêt à ce que ça soit fait sur un
plan volontariste avec un délai
d'adaptation puisque de toute façon
c'est maintenant à rennes alors faut-il
aller plus loin ma conviction c'est que
bien évidemment il faut aller plus loin
là je reviens d'italie où il ya eu un
moratoire sur les néonicotinoïdes donc
alors qu'avant on me disait que c'était
interdit au niveau européen j'observe
que l'italie a fait un moratoire sur les
néonicotinoïdes et donc on aura ce débat
et dans la loi de transition énergétique
et dans la loi sur la biodiversité
puisque de toute façon ce moratoire a
déjà été votée il ya effectivement vous
savez des grandes interrogations du côté
du monde agricole
ce qui est logique ce qui est
respectable il faut voir comment ce
aussi est ce qu on fait évoluer les
pratiques agricoles avec quels produits
de substitution mais il est bien évident
que l'utilisation d'un certain nombre de
substances
dans le milieu agricole se retourne
contre l'agriculteur eux mêmes puissent
quand tu entres les touts les
pollinisateurs en particulier c'est
l'agriculture elle même qui s'affaiblit
donc je crois que là aussi à des
évolutions très forte des mentalités
parce que enfin les filières qui sont
dominantes sur la vente des
phytosanitaires commencent à comprendre
que maintenant il y aura plus de retour
en arrière et qu'on va avancer aussi
avec des normes avec des règles et quand
on fait preuve effectivement
d'hésitation ou d'aller retour à ce
moment-là l'aider les acteurs
économiques ne se met pas dans laxe il
faut maintenant qu'ils se mettent dans
l'acte parce que dans d'autres pays on
avance et on trouve des produits de
substitution qui correspond de non
seulement à l'intérêt de l'agriculture
mais aussi intérêt général
merci madame la ministre alors que
madame lévis vous avez pas répondu à ma
question excuses matin temps passe le
président sur le diesel sûr que sur la
seule interdiction du diesel oui et le
aujourd'hui à deux choses on n'est plus
dans les logiques d'interdiction du ruf
grâce à l'interdiction du diesel du jour
au lendemain
regardez déjà la difficulté du conte a
encouragé pendant des années et des
années des années l'achat de véhicules
diesel langue aussi savoir raison garder
est pragmatique et regarder la réalité
de la situation
deuxièmement les constructeurs font des
efforts considérables puisque
aujourd'hui il ya des véhicules beaucoup
moins polluant des voitures diesel
beaucoup moins polluant jeu mais
j'observe que la tête de vous devriez
aller même beaucoup plus loin sur votre
question puisqu'on est à quelques mois
de la coupe 21
on est sur la problématique de
l'utilisation des énergies fossiles et
la vraie question c'est comment est-ce
qu'on prépare l'après pétrole
c'est pas un problème de guerre entre le
diesel et l'essence c'est comment est-ce
qu'on prépare l'après pétrole avec une
mobilité électrique ou autres une
mobilité propre qui n'utilisent plus les
énergies fossiles
la vraie question elle est là et ce
qu'ils trouvent ce qui est ce qu'il faut
vraiment accéléré c'est la mobilité
propre de l'après pétrole sans énergie
fossile
merci madame la ministre je vous propose
rassurez-vous tout le monde va voir la
parole tout de suite s'il est d'accord
démoniste puisque chacun a demandé la
parole je vais donc
me revenir une lourde responsabilité
c'est simplement de la distribuer et je
vous demande chers collègues le plus con
si possible pour nous offrir la
possibilité d'avoir le maximum de
réponses madame tocqueville qui s'il
vous plaît merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre vous avez abordé les
problèmes que rencontre le monde
agricole et je suis particulièrement
sensible étant sénatrice de
seine-maritime où l'activité agricole
est encore importante
je suis inquiète parce que lorsque nous
discutons avec les exploitants agricoles
moi j'ai l'impression que ils ont encore
tendance à minimiser les conséquences
néfastes pour eux-mêmes et c'était un
petit peu inquiétant parce que je pense
que non seulement la pollution de l'air
est grave mais les exploitants agricoles
ne voit pas immédiatement les
conséquences de la pollution qui va les
frapper et on se rend compte aujourd'hui
que à 20 ans à 30 ans des exploitants
agricoles commencent à souffrir de
maladies qui me semble-t-il ne
sensibilisent pas encore suffisamment
les jeunes exploitants agricoles donc
vous avez mentionné le fait que des
tables rondes sont en cours pourriez
vous nous préciser la forme que prennent
ces tables rondes
comment s'organise la réflexion avec les
chambres d'agriculture et est-ce que des
échéances sont envisagées qui poseront
des incitations voir des obligations aux
exploitants agricoles je dirais presque
malgré eux
je vous remercie merci notre collègue
jacques chiron
je me présente du sénateur élu à
grenoble donc vous comprendrez que après
vos autres les informations vous avez
donné on est on est particulièrement
sensible à grenoble vous conseillez la
configuration de cette ville une cuvette
qui est particulièrement polluée dû aux
vents dominants qui rapatriera balle à
la pollution sur le sur le sol nous
avons nous avons fait une
expérimentation avec de petits véhicules
électriques d'un constructeur
une soixantaine qui sont mis à
disposition dans le cadre d'une cycle
d'autopartage l'ademe d'ailleurs apporté
son aide de son ami l'euro en 2013 et
ses essais particulièrement je dirais
bénéfique
par contre c'est scop c'est à dire si
c'est sic d'autopartage ne pourrait-elle
pas bénéficié au niveau de la prime de
la prime plus c'est à dire les 10000
euros
aujourd'hui elle bénéficie d'une prime
normal comme à n'importe quelle
entreprise de 6000 6800 euros pour moi
quelque chose comme ça et est-ce qu'à
partir du moment où c'est une scop dans
le cadre de l'auto partage c'est à dire
en dire en direction des particuliers
on ne pourrait pas faire bénéficier ccc
scop d'une prime supérieure comme
puisqu'elle s'adresse plutôt aux
particuliers et donc b pourrait
bénéficier d'une prime sur sub
supplémentaire sachant qu' il faut il
faut inciter nos notre nos concitoyens
aller de plus en plus vers ce steam de
ce système de déplacement et de et de
location de véhicules merci merci je
suis recoller guy louis
madame la ministre
le diagnostic est partagé on a non
seulement en contentieux repères donc il
reconnu
par bruxelles de la situation qui est la
nôtre en france mais je rappellerai que
nous avons quarante mille morts
prématurées et 40 mille morts
prématurées en france c'est beaucoup et
ce sont notamment les plus jeunes et les
plus âgés qui souffrent de cette
pollution
alors quand vous avez annoncé tout à
l'heure qu'il y avait une amélioration
en 2014
je vois que vous êtes une ministre
optimiste en fait ce qui s'est passé en
2014 c'est que nous avons eu des
conditions climatiques météorologiques
favorables et du coup ça a baissé
maintenant sur le fond je ne suis pas
sûr qu'il y ait une baisse totale
par ailleurs au niveau du sénat avec la
commission du développement durable nous
avons créé une commission sur le diesel
pour se rendre compte pour savoir ce
qu'il en était réellement effectivement
on découvre un certain nombre de choses
et notamment des sources de pollution
qu'on avait tendance à oublier nous
travaillons dans ce domaine là et je
pense qu'on aura une position équilibrée
en fonction de ce que nous venons
d'apprendre mais vous avez l'encore
réseau c'est l'après pétrole c'est le
l'énergie fossile qu'il va falloir
diminuer alors le projet de loi sur la
transition énergétique pour l'aide
financière pour les véhicules
électriques nous ne pouvons qu'être
favorable après le livre vert et sur
l'indemnité kilométrique vélo en tant
que rapporteur je me suis battu pour que
ce soient inscrits et je vous dirai
madame la ministre qu'il faut se
préparer aussi dans un deuxième temps
mais ça arrive déjà au japon aujourd'hui
à l'hydrogène
le cadre législatif pour les bus vous
avez là dessus évoluer madame la
ministre et j'en suis très heureux dans
la mesure où vous avez désormais un
classement de très faibles émissions et
de faibles émissions
ce qui me paraît être justifiée et la
mesure convient effectivement à
l'ensemble des autorités de transport
après cette modification alors j'ai deux
questions une question sur la santé nous
n'avez
vous n'avez pas aborder la pollution
intérieure alors qu'elle est souvent
supérieur à la pollution extérieure et
pour avoir été rapporteur du grenelle 2
de l'environnement
j'avais déjà cette impression là la
deuxième problème sur la santé vous
n'avez pas non plus abordé les
particules fines
ces particules fines pour lequel j'ai
demandé en tant que rapporteur qu'elle
soit désormais contrôlés dans la loi de
transition énergétique parce qu'on
s'aperçoit que là encore elle joue un
rôle négatif
c'est un élément pollueurs majeur là
aussi avec des sources très diversifiés
d'ailleurs et puis la deuxième question
portera sur le niveau financier vous
nous avez dit l'écotaxe n'a pas été
supprimée j'en prends bonne note mais
est-ce que vous arriverez
est-ce que vous pouvez vous engager sur
la pérennité de cette écotaxe et à quel
niveau
à quel niveau sachant qu'il nous
faudrait un milliard deux cents millions
au niveau de la fuite
si nous voulons continuer à assurer les
financements des infrastructures et
enfin sur les transports publics
il y à une mesure contradictoires vous
avez augmenté
le gouvernement propose d'augmenter les
seuils sociaux de 9 à 11
c'est très bien mesure formidable sauf
que ça impacte directement le versement
de transport et cela signifie un
transfert financier en centaines de
millions d'euros
hogarth nous avons fait ces évaluations
là sur les collectivités sur les
autorités de transports alors que l'on
charge des seuils d'accord mais que l'on
transfère pas une nouvelle charge sur
les collectivités
merci nous poursuivons ma collègue
evelyne didier merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre nous aurons
l'occasion effectivement dans le débat
la loi transition énergétique de revenir
sur un certain nombre de sujets et les
mesures qui sont dans ce texte vont
concourir à améliorer les choses
j'ai trois questions premièrement le
rapport de l'ansès on en parle beaucoup
avez vous une idée
2 quand il va pouvoir sortir parce que
nous attendons ses travaux avec
impatience dans plusieurs domaines
la deuxième question est ce que l'on
considère que les transports
ferroviaires sont une solution dans les
transports vous
on a cité les véhicules électriques bien
entendu on est dans on imagine qu'on va
vers l'après pétrole et donc est ce
qu'on considère que la solution pour le
transport en particulier collectif c'est
par exemple le transport ferroviaire et
qu'elles sont
qu'est-ce que ça ça veut dire ensuite
pour les mesures à prendre
troisième chose on sait bien qu'on va
pas pouvoir tout régler le même jour
mais que lorsque des mesures sont
prévues dans une loi par exemple ou dans
dance et des circulaires ce qui est
important c'est qu'elles soient suivies
d'effets est-ce que vous avez une idée
de la manière dont vous allez pouvoir
suivre de près les mesures qui sont
prévus dans la loi prévue dans les
circulaires de telle sorte que on
s'assure de l'effectivité du du travail
réalisé et dernière question la qualité
de l'air on l'a vu dans cette mission
elle touche tous les citoyens mais elle
touche également les citoyens les
travailleurs dans le monde du travail il
y a aujourd'hui des seuils différents
d'acceptabilité pour le citoyen
ordinaire et pour le monde du travail
qu'en est il de la réflexion sur ce
sujet je vous remercie
merci ma chère collègue martial bourquin
oui madame la ministre je voudrais
j'aurai tout d'abord remarqué que votre
position concernant le roundup est une
position courageuse comme vous l'avez
prise il ya quelques temps sur le
bisphénol a
c'est important parce que les lobbys
sont importants aussi en face de vous et
vous osez prendre des positions comme
celles ci feront leur marque et il faut
le saluer et je dois vous dire que pour
les particuliers c'est un premier pas
il faudra qu'on suit on aborde la
question des professionnels lorsque ça
va avec je le glyphosate maintenant a
été reconnu comme cancérigène par l'om s
on sait très bien qu'on fonctionne avec
l'europe sur ces questions et comment il
faudra un jour se passer de ces produits
qui sont non seulement néfaste pour la
santé pour nos sols pour nos écosystèmes
et franchement faut le faire ce que vous
avez fait d'une certaine façon moi je
salue est ce que madame la ministre on
pourrait retravailler sur les aides
européennes concernant l'agriculture est
ce qu on sait qu'elles sont importantes
pour redéployer autrement une
agriculture plus soutenable aujourd'hui
vu la concurrence
vu la concurrence entre pays européens
il est important que les aides
européennes puissent permettre un
développement beaucoup plus soutenable
et que certains produits au niveau de
l'europe soit comment directement
directement proscrit directement
proscrit voilà je pense que sur les
alternatifs aura plancher aussi parce
que supprimer un herbicide puis une pâle
remplacé pour les professeurs ça pose un
problème il faudrait travailler aussi
sur les les commandes
les alternatives je vous avais aussi
interrogé sur la question des
traitements des grumes à ciel ouvert ce
que la filière bois qui le fait c'est
ces produits sont hautement toxiques
il ya eu des ex des essais de
l'universite franche comté avec des sûr
qu'ils provenaient de ces traitements
ça détruit complètement les écosystèmes
et on continue à ciel ouvert pour l'air
et pour les sols de est ce que lui il ne
faut pas d interdiction et faire en
sorte que ces traitements là soient
réservées en vase clos c'est à dire
réservé dans des dans des entreprises
qui seraient équipés comme les cabines
de peinture
dernière chose à la ministre sur le
diesel
j'étais à une réunion il ya peu de temps
on me disait que le diesel euro 6 et
norme euro 6 et est moins polluant que
l'essence est ce que nous pourrions
avoir sur ces questions un méta point de
vue que des analyses
parce que vous savez très bien quand on
met le diesel depuis qu'on parle de tous
les diesels ceux qui n'ont pas de filtre
à particules sont extrêmement polluant
ceux qui ont un filtre à particules sont
beaucoup moins polluant mais la norme
euro 6 on nous dit que et surtout les
nouveaux moteurs que toutes les marques
s'apprête à sortir dans dans 17 et en 18
2017 2018 on eût dit qu'ils sont
beaucoup moins polluant que les moteurs
essence
est-ce que sur ces questions vous pouvez
nous éclairer merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue fabienne keller s'il vous plaît
si beaucoup monsieur le président de me
passer la parole les sujets commencent à
converger on retrouve certains thèmes
avons toujours madame la ministre je
voudrais vous remercier d'être là mais
vous interroger sur la suppression de
l'écotaxe à la suite de la râpe madame
le rapporteur leila aichi et et louis
c'était une ressource importante pour la
fit pour organiser le transfert du mode
de transport individuel verts notamment
le ferroviaire c'est une recette qui est
perdu nous le vivons d'autant plus mal
moi je suis frontalière de l'allemagne
on voit bien le l'effet de l'ama août
allemande de d'apaisement et de
d'encouragement à d'autres modes de
transport des marchandises
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner des
pistes sur les autres financements que
vous envisagez de mettre en oeuvre si on
veut réaliser la transition énergétique
de manière concrète il faudra des
ressources financières vous avez un
dispositif d'encouragement pour les
véhicules électriques si on veut élargir
ce dispositif comme le président martial
saddier levoca l'instant que c'est un
levier efficace pour l'amélioration de
la qualité de l'air il faut une
ressource financière
avez vous des pistes à ce sujet deuxième
question la loi makrout nous sommes en
train d'examiner en commission spéciale
ouvre la voie à des lignes de bus
nombreuses qui d'ailleurs sont déjà
annoncés sur les sites internet des
autocaristes faisant craindre un
transfert assez massif du train vers le
but vous avez annoncé qu'ils auraient
les normes particulières pour ces bus
mais comment se feront elles appliquées
est ce que dans tous les cas on ne peut
pas craindre puisque le bilan pour la
pollution de l'air du train bien
meilleure puisque l'essentiel des traces
quand même électrique que ceux du bus
quels impacts de ce transfert annoncé
pour la pollution de l'air troisième
sujet un peu vaste j'ai eu le plaisir de
faire un rapport sur le véhicule
écologique avec denis baupin là aussi si
le véhicule électrique est d'une des
pistes il y en a d'autres notamment la
réduction du poids du véhicule
le paradoxe du véhicule électrique et en
3d des batteries qui mécaniquement à
moteur constant génère un besoin
énergétique supérieur j'adore le vélo
j'adore le vélo électrique qui est une
formule intéressante mais quel
dispositif d'encouragement pour des
véhicules intermédiaires un peu plus
protecteur mais qui peuvent représenter
de vrai levier sur la baisse du poids en
améliorant également la motorisation une
baisse très significative
de leur contribution à la pollution de
l'air enfin dernier point et pardon le
quatrième j'ai eu le bonheur de réaliser
à la commission des finances des études
successives sur les contentieux européen
en matière de la pollution de l'air
malheureusement tout ça est très
inertielle comme vous l'avez rappelé
madame l'ami ça met du temps pour
améliorer la qualité de l'air on a vu
lors de leurs auditions précédentes que
les ppa sont en train d'être prescrits
ou ils sont assez récent quels risques
là aussi financier d'un contentieux
dès lors que sur les pm10 nous avons
déjà l'avis motivé je rappelle que la
commission a donné il ya quelques années
des règles de calcul sur les sur le coup
des contentieux qui aboutirait à une
condamnation de la france jours la cible
merci ma chère collègue françois
grosdidier oui donc françois cau des
sénateurs ump de la moselle est normal
et on a pas d'enjeu politique je tiens à
dire que je suis tout à fait d'accord et
ce qu'on dit mes prédécesseurs et même
le sénateur bourquin sur même les
félicitations qu'il a pu vous adresser
sur votre indépendance vis-à-vis ont
pris de l'industrie chimique sur le
bisphénol a ou sur le round up serait
peut-être plus critique pour revenir sur
le sujet est en elle une demoiselle sur
l'éco taxe poids lourds
parce que
le dire est que d'abord pour prendre le
problème de façon plus globale
si nos concitoyens ont souvent un
problème avec l'écologie c'est que d'une
part à bord c'est un point à la fois de
clarté de responsabilité de clarté ça
doit être la clarté sur les messages
alors certains messages sont assez
floues surtout lorsqu'on n'est pas dans
la certitude un con mais en noble
principe de précaution parfois puisque
celui de prévention et notamment sur des
sujets comme les pesticides sur julie
tout ce qui nous intéresse ou des effets
sont à long terme
produisez maladie aux causes
multifactorielles quoi c'est difficile
de parler avec des certitudes absolues
même si aujourd'hui on est plus en plus
conforté sur l'établissement de
certaines vérités dérangeantes mais mais
sur les responsabilités on voit bien
qu'à chaque fois par exemple comprend
une mesure limitative de la circulation
routière on aura défenseur des
automobilistes qui vont expliquer le
rôle très marginale automobile par
rapport aux autres sources d'émission de
particules et que en attendant trop
tendance dans le flou des
responsabilités a cherché à évacuer pour
chacun sa responsabilité pour celle de
l'autre donc si on veut que que toutes
responsabilités collectives fois su avec
précision il faut être précis sur la
responsabilité de chacun
alors par exemple sur le problème du
diesel et de l'essence
on a un problème le discours et panet
les réflective m'en venir avec précision
sur est ce que la nouvelle norme euro 6
et non polluant et s on sait plus si
c'est en ville qu'on doit proscrire le
diesel est pas à sur les longs trajets
est-ce que sur un long trajet est est-ce
qu'il vaut pas mieux du diesel qui est
moins de co2 et avec des pots
catalytiques qui sont bien chaud et qui
marchait bien le train comme on ne peut
pas tout le temps surtout quand on
supprime certains trains bon donc
ou est-ce qu'en vite il faut absolument
encourager uniquement les sens ou
l'hybride lire électrique essence mais
là on n'est pas sur des vérités établies
alors on a les constructeurs nationaux
qui aujourd'hui c'est tant mieux on
tendance à remplacer le petit diesel par
deux de l'essence mais pour l'instant le
discours public est flou est ce qu'on
doit aller sur la fin disait alors bien
sûr le mieux stran électrique
mais en attendant quelle est la décision
responsable c'est pas clair alors sur
ensuite le principe du pollueur payeur
je crois que nos concitoyens sont acquis
mais c'est pas ce qui est mise en oeuvre
alors on peut évoquer des pollutions
agricoles ou industrielles mais sur le
transport on me dit l'éco taxe poids
lourds finalement n'est pas volée elle
est remplacée par une taxe de 2 centimes
sur le diesel quoi je suis élu de la
moselle
je sais que les poids lourds font le
plein au luxembourg ils ont par attac et
vont descendre jusqu'en espagne avec le
carburant prise en poids lourds et et
nos concitoyens ont un immense sentiment
d'injustice
quant à eux vont payer les deux centimes
de plus sur le diesel que les petits
artistes quoi ou que des petites
entreprises payent le versement
transport qu'on envisage même des
autoroutes de desserte qui sert pour les
trajets pendulaires
on envisage aujourd'hui le péage par
exemple sur l'a31 dans cette même région
alors même que le transit international
y échappent
et je crois aussi que on en serait
beaucoup plus efficace en pédagogie on
renforcerait l'acceptabilité si on
donnait vraiment le sentiment qu'on est
dans la mise en oeuvre du principe du
pollueur payeur
j'aurais j'aurais eu d'autres points
mais je vais me faire disputer par le
rapporteur donc je m'arrête là donc par
le président qui n'est pas là pour
discuter qui est là vous l'avez compris
pour distribuer la parole et vous posez
deux très courtes question madame la
ministre
puisque je me plie bien volontiers la
concision où en est on aujourd'hui de
l'élaboration du plan de réduction des
émissions de polluants atmosphériques
étaient prévus pour la fin de l'année
avec une évaluation à mi 2015
deuxième question comment le ministère
dont vous avez la charge
perçoit-il et surtout envisage-t-il
l'évolution du financement des
associations agréées de surveillance de
la qualité de l'air vous avez bien
compris que leur financement est loin
d'être assuré qu'il ne croit plus tôt
actuellement madame la ministre je vous
remercie
si on pouvait avoir dans un petit quart
d'heure l'ensemble de vos réponses à la
fois pour respecter votre temps et puis
également parce que vous avez des
collègues avoue du gouvernement qui sont
je dirais dans les starting blocks et
d'un empire des prouesses
donc après ce top ville vous avez
souligné effectivement le fait que les
pollutions agricoles frappe d'abord les
agriculteurs et c'est vrai et d'ailleurs
on le sait depuis longtemps ça a été
longtemps taboue mais pour les élus
ruraux non j'ai été en tant que députée
des deux sèvres
on savait pas ce qu'on voyait les
statistiques de la mutualité sociale
agricole et on savait déjà le taux de
cancer beaucoup plus élevés pour les
agriculteurs beaucoup plus élevés pour
les viticulteurs
on sait aujourd'hui et heureusement que
ces informations maintenant s'en sont
remis sur la table notamment les
problèmes de cancer il ya eu un rapport
récent sur les malformations génitales
des bébés dans l'été dans les zones où
il ya eu beaucoup d'utilisation de
pesticides on voit dans certaines
régions de france aussi l'âge de la
puberté qui s'est dramatiquement qui
dramatiquement diminué certaine petite
fille de 8 ans ont déjà le sont déjà
l'âge de la puberté et on sait
maintenant que c'est dû aux produits
phytosanitaires il est évident comme ça
a été dit par plusieurs d'entre vous qui
vaut vraiment maintenant accélérer la
transition agricoles vers l'agriculture
vers et en particulier dans la
viticulture et est évident qu'un jour
d'ailleurs tous les vignobles seront bio
on le voit maintenant même les grands
crus se disent évolué vers le bio et on
se dira même et comment ça a pu durer
aussi longtemps que des viticulteurs
eux-mêmes si nos cultes finalement des
maladies extrêmement grave
j'étais autres jours dans une ville bio
et ça m'a fait ça m'a vraiment touché
parce que l'agriculteur bio disait le
viticulteur bio disait en femmes et
enfants peuvent jouer dans la vigne donc
ils savent en plus ce qu'ils subissent
directement par un système
d'intermédiaires qui voilà qui
s'enrichit aussi sur sur ce type de
pratiques
monsieur jacques chinon sur les vous
demander si les 10000 euros peuvent être
attribuées aux entreprises d'autopartage
alors la réponse malheureusement n'est
pas positif pourquoi parce que en
contrepartie de ces 10000 euros il ya
l'obligation de mettre à la casse un
vieux véhicule diesel
donc vous voyez c'est pour éliminer un
vieux véhicule mais bon on peut regarder
comment est-ce qu'on peut avantager
compris fiscalement pourquoi pas
faudrait il faudrait regarder ce que
l'on peut faire pour encourager les
sociétés se partagent le louis
vous avez posé la question des
pollutions intérieures c'est un sujet
que vous connaissez bien effectivement
c'est qu'ils étaient vous êtes occupé de
activement dans le dans le grenelle de
l'environnement donc c'est un sujet
qu'il faut absolument pas laissé de côté
j'ai évoqué de thaler notamment avec les
prod les problèmes de revêtements de
sols l'épreuve de peinture les problèmes
d'utilisation des produits de nettoyage
qui contiennent des néonicotinoïdes et
caetera et donc un guide pratique que
j'ai fait faire par le ministère sur le
choix des des erreurs des revêtements le
choix des produits d'entretien pour que
effectivement on ne ne puisse pas se
polluer sans même le savoir
donc ça c'est très important que les
services municipaux en particulier que
tous les gestionnaires des lieux
d'accueil du public soit informé de ces
sont informés de ces choix qui s'offrent
à eux pour diminuer la pollution
intérieure
les particules fines c'est un sujet
aussi très importants qui doivent faire
l'objet d'une mesure en tant que tel les
ressources de lafitte les balais 200e
seront sont maintenus bien évidemment il
n'ya pas deux sentiments plus pour
l'instant mais ils sont laissons là donc
ils continuent à alimenter la fuite
et sur la question des seuils sociaux
qu'on avait lobé sur laquelle on avait
l'occasion de deux d'évoquer
effectivement c'était une observation
très judicieuse que j'ai transmis
immédiatement aux ministres compétents
qui est chargé de suivre le ce projet le
doigt sur les seuils sociaux pour qu' il
puisse y avoir une réponse très précise
à la question que vous soulevez evelyne
didier le rapport de l'ansés va nous
l'aurons je pense au début d'année
prochaine
donc on pourra vous le communiqué
également rapidement les transports
ferroviaires bien évidemment les
transports ferroviaires font partie des
transports propres
j'ajoute que on aimerait bien voir aussi
se développer transport du fret
ferroviaire parce que c'est quand même
aussi l'alternative aux camions comment
suivre les mesures prévues je pense
qu'on pourra les suisses dans le cadre
du conseil national de la transition
écologique ou à la fois parce que je
vais faire en sorte qu'au moment la
promulgation de la loi sur la transition
énergétique avec le volet transports
propres les textes d'application soit
prêt au moment de la promulgation
donc c'est un travail considérable dans
kg engagé les services de mon ministère
et en même temps pourront nous pourrons
voir avec le conseil national de la
transition écologique comment assurer le
suivi des actions à la fois
réglementaires et des projets et des
appels à projets qui vont avec
monsieur martial bourquin merci pour vos
encouragements sur l'élimination du
roundup serait que c'est pas facile
parce que quand même à des à des lobbys
très important il est évident qu'après
il faut les éliminer partout et je pense
que nous avons un rôle pédagogique parce
que vous comprenez si on commence par
les particuliers là où j'ai également la
possibilité d'agir et que je le fais
quand même temps les communes s'engagent
dans l'appel à projets du ministère sur
territoire terre saine zéro pesticide et
je vois la montée en puissance des
communes qui élimine ça y est les
pesticides dans les jardins publics
j'ai lancé en tant que miss de tutelle
des transports aussi l'élimination des
pesticides sur tous les bords de routes
nationales avec des pratiques de fauche
tardive pour et figurez vous que les
bordures de routes nationales à la
totalité de ses bordures c'est
l'équivalent de la totalité de surfaces
des parcs nationaux
donc voyez des mesures qui paraissent
accessoires deviennent centrale dès lors
qu'elles sont massives et qu'elle
s'applique sur le sol en temps
l'ensemble du territoire national
retravailler sur les aides europe est
évident et d'ailleurs j'observe que au
niveau européen les miss de
l'environnement pousse de plus en plus
pour qui des mutations très forte vers
l'agriculture verte est en phase sur la
question du traitement des grumes
il ya d'autres problèmes comme ça de
traitement effectivement soit par
agricole soit industriel en plein air
c'est ce sont des produits hautement
toxiques et c'est vrai que dans les
plans locaux de diminution de la
pollution il ne faut pas oublier ces
sujets là et c'est vrai que suite à
votre interpellation ce sont des thèmes
que la direction de la prévention des
risques du ministère va intégrer à ses
appels d'offres support est à ses
instructions sur le diesel
alors est-ce que c'est l'euro si c'est
moins polluants ou pas soyons bien
clairs ce n'est pas moins polluant il ya
moins de co2 c'est vrai mais à plus de
particules et plus d'oxydé d'azoté dont
il faut donner acte quand même aux
industriels du 10è des efforts qu'ils
font parce qu'il ya moins de co2
effectivement mais il ya encore plus de
particules et plus d'oxydé d'azoté que
pour l'essence et comme je disais
globalement n'opposons pas le disais la
naissance est ce qu'il faut c'est s'est
passé au delà et préparer l'après
pétrole
madame fabienne keller vous avez évoqué
l'écotaxe avec votre collègue françois
grosdidier
effectivement je rappelle que l'écotaxe
était 25% minimum de coût de
fonctionnement et j'estime que quand on
a un état après les impôts c'est la
totalité qui doit être restitué aux
actions donc je vais pas revenir sur les
défauts du système tel qu'il avait été
imaginé une usine à gaz en jeu notait
qu'il avait été imaginé sans parler des
problèmes de 2 débute en bretagne où
c'est rien dans des territoires qui
n'était pas une territoires traversés
considéré comme territoire de transit
pour les poids lourds du nord au sud de
l'europe
alors il ya une solution c'est la mise à
disposition de ces portiques aux régions
et aux départements concernés
la région ile de france a déjà fait
cette demande donc les portiques
installée en région ile de france seront
mis à disposition des régions ou des
départements traversés qui le souhaitent
et c'est vrai que la région ile de
france où les régions côtières telles
que la vôtre moselle alsace sont
directement impactés par des dispositifs
allemand payant et donc des
détournements de trafic mais l' avantage
ce sera que ces régions pourront
prélever directement au passage sous le
portique les taxes qui vont avec le
passage des camions et pas renvoyer à un
système de satellites qui est envoyé
dans un système d'ordinateurs à metz est
lui même renvoyé vers je ne sais quoi
ensuite des factures qui arrivait au
d'homicide et des opérateurs qui entre
temps aurait pu se délocaliser ailleurs
ensuite retrouver les adresses envoyer
les factures a posteriori enfin un
système à mon avis qui était absolument
ingérable et qui en plus entraîner
blocage du pays parce que les compagnies
de transport ne comprenait pas qu'au
passage 10 et 25 % de prélèvement de ce
qu'ils avaient payé en coûts de
fonctionnement de ce dispositif
donc dans un premier temps il ya les
deux centimes qui vont lafitte et dans
un second temps les régions les
départements qui veulent bénéficier des
portiques avec des systèmes technologies
beaucoup plus simple emmanuel comme sur
les autoroutes les camions passent et
les régions et les départements prélève
le paiement le péage qui sera
entièrement restituée aux départements
et aux régions qui auront fait le choix
de garder ces portiques et d'en définir
mu âge et les tarifs sur la loue à
maquereau est effectivement vous avez
complètement raison il faudrait que et
bus qui circulent les gens appelaient
d'ailleurs son intention soit des buts
propre et ça permettra aussi de faire un
marché se leva pour faciliter de la mise
au point et la vente des transports
collectifs propres vous aviez faire
rapport avec denis baupin quels
dispositifs d'encouragement me
demandez-vous je crois que on s'en est
inspiré d'ailleurs de ce rapport non je
vous félicite avec denis baupin
notamment pour le volet transports
propres de la transition énergétique et
pour le pour l'électrique
oui et le déploiement des bornes
électriques mais ça aussi ça relève
finalement des agglomérations et dans le
cadre de l'appel à projets que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure il va
appartenir aux villes aidé par le
ministère de mettre en place des
transports électriques performants et de
réinventer les déplacements urbains
pense que c'est vraiment la civilisation
de la villa qui est en jeu et qui est
vraiment il ya beaucoup des solutions de
l'imagination de la mobilisation des
citoyens du covoiturage etc
françois grosdidier donc j'ai répondu
sur l'écotaxe et sur le diesel également
je pense avoir répondu aux
interrogations
voilà monsieur le président vous avez
conclu par donc une question sur le plan
de réduction des émissions de polluants
qui constitue donc la stratégie et
nationales et programme d'action en
faveur de la qualité de l'air pour la
période 2016-2020 donc c'est vrai que
c'est un sujet très important
les réflexions sont engagées donc depuis
la fin de l'année dernière les comités
de pilotage s'est réuni plusieurs fois
comme j'ai dit à l'heure il y avait un
point d'étape que je pourrais vous
communiquer qui a été présentée conseil
national de l'air que j'ai réuni le 2
juin et aujourd'hui nous avons des
réunions sectorielles et qui seront dont
elle sera rendue compte d'abord avant le
30e au moment au début juillet et début
juin 30 juin 2016 pour la finalisation
mais d'ici là il y a quatre groupes de
travail qui sont mis en place
comment offrir des avantages aux
utilisateurs des véhicules moins
polluants grâce au certificat de la
qualité de l'air comment encourager les
élus locaux à s'engager à travers les
appels à projets et même au delà
quel cadre pérenne peut-on donner à la
lutte contre la pollution grâce aux
mesures du projet de loi de transition
énergétique
donc je pense que nous pourrons faire
converger l'ensemble de ses
préoccupations pour à la fois
données quelles sont les nouvelles
normes le contenu des appels à projets
mais aussi les accompagnements
financiers qui vont avec
mais suite à votre question je vais
essayer de bien repréciser donné le
calendrier et les échéances pour pouvoir
également vous le communiquer sur le
financement des associations
actuellement il y a les crédits
budgétaires de l'état
17 millions d'euros par an tu quand même
pas rien les subventions versées par les
collectivités 14 millions d'euros par an
les dons effectués par les industriels
qui donne donc fallait donc qui donne
droit à déduction du montant de la taxe
générale sur les activités polluantes
auxquelles ils sont assujettis branly
1271 1000 euros par site ou de 25% du
montant de la tgap du c'est l'équivalent
de 15 à 20 millions d'euros sont ainsi
reverser le budget de fonctionnement
annuel des associations et de 45 à 50
millions d'euros
et bien évidemment tout ça et rediscuté
lors de chaque vote du budget que je je
compte sur votre soutien
mais ce qui veut dire aussi qu'en
contrepartie je pense qu'on est aussi en
mesure de demander à ces associations
aussi des comptes rendus de leur action
et décoder un suivi de leur efficacité
une évaluation de leurs travaux des
conventions qu'ils peuvent est également
contrôlée et qu'on puisse contrôler
clairement l'utilisation de ces fonds
que vraiment il soit aussi opérationnel
est utile et pour obtenir les résultats
que nous recherchons tous merci madame
la ministre c'est le cas je vais
proposer une heure juste trente secondes
à madame la rapporteure parce que
vraiment il faut que je suis dernière du
temps madame la ministre simplement
revenir sur le sujet du diesel ça fait
plus de trente deux ans qu'on fait que
le diesel est cancérigène nous sommes
dans un pays qui a supprimé plus de cent
mille emplois dans l'automobile
nous avons dans le cadre de la coop 21
dans le département supprimé en moins de
deux ans trois mille emplois nous allons
devoir dans le cadre justement
précisément de la cap 21 a importé plus
de ddl électrique
nous revenons nous avons fait une nous
sommes déplacés dans la région enfin
dans le nord nous avons auditionné
renault et toyota précisément ces
derniers considèrent que justement on ne
va pas assez loin dans les normes que
les technologies avancent pour reprendre
ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure vous
dit à juste titre qu'il faut assurer la
transition aux énergies fossiles pour
autant l'ademe en 2013 a financé à
hauteur de 110 millions d'euros
les moteurs hybrides essence et diesel
alors même que nous avons des
technologies type hydrogène électrique
est-ce qu'il ya pas une forme de
d'incohérences puisque comme je le
disais dans mon préambule ça fait plus
de trente deux ans qu'on sait que le
diesel est cancérigène est ce qu'on
n'est pas plutôt dans une impasse dans
une impasse économique les emplois de
demain sont les emplois liés au
développement durable aux technologies
nouvelles et le désert appartient à un
temps à un temps passé est ce qu'il n'ya
pas une forme justement de résistance ou
de de facilité à céder sur disons les
choses le lobby le lobby du diesel
puisque il existe des technologies
confèrent les échanges que nous avons
eus avec toyota et renault qui explicite
que justement nous n'allons pas assez
loin
merci madame ministre
l'ap a été versée finalement donc là je
crois que les choses sont cohérentes
deuxièmement il faut savoir ce que l'on
veut soit on dit effectivement qu'il ya
quarante mille morts prématurées à cause
de la pollution mais à ce moment là on
prend des mesures beaucoup plus
radicales compris vous vous êtes élu de
paris
déployer encore du diesel dans paris
voyez aussi un compte pas pour pardon
mais il ya aussi une contradiction entre
les discours et les actes quand j'ai dit
récemment comment se fait-il qu'ils
entendent d'ailleurs été nommé justement
comment se fait-il qu'ils aient de la
région parisienne comment se fait-il que
des bus diesel dans paris des taxis
diesel dans paris et que on nous dise
mais yahia 20000 à 40000 mort prématurée
mais là on arrête tout de suite et on
dit ben voila et non maintenant les
taxis seront électriques les bus seront
électriques pourquoi c'est si lent donc
y attendait tous le comptable de ce qui
est fait voyez donc moi je veux bien
qu'on ait une énergie anti diesel c'est
vrai qu'il ya des pollutions mais en
même temps à ce moment là il faut passer
à l'action
donc il ya une contradiction entre le
voyez le côté dramatique de constats et
la faiblesse des actions qui vont avec
et quand je dis mais enfin comment
voulez vous que les gens comprennent
qu'on leur dira que vous allez avoir un
calicot pour dire notre voiture est
polluante et ils sortent dans la rue et
voit les ddd fumée noire qui s'échappe
des taxis et des transports collectifs
cnt c'est incompréhensible
donc vraiment et que je pense que un
moment et voilà il faut que la société
prenne en effet des décisions radicales
comme pour reprendre euh pardon mais
madame anne masson et l'emmena contexte
par exemple dans le département soit on
vient de faire une encyclique qui est
exceptionnel qui est juste
exceptionnelle qui appelle à une
révolution écologique qui appelle une
écologie radicale et bien dans ces
domaines là soyons et ayant en effet une
écologie radicale et un moment fixons
des échéances entraîneur en compte aussi
de l'implication c'est à dire des phares
étaient dans les trente faveur merci
pour votre disponibilité de temps qu'au
sénat on sait que être radical c'est
ce à plusieurs acceptions voilà voilà
pour cette audition de ségolène royal la
ministre de l'écologie qui a été entendu
par les sénateurs de la commission d'
enquête sur le coût économique et
financier de la pollution de l'air vous
avez pu entendre qu'il ya eu certains
vous êtes échange assez vif avec la
sénatrice écologiste rapporteur de cette
commission denquête elle et il a écrit
avec ségolène royal notamment attaqué
sur sa politique en matière de diesel la
sénatrice a regretté que le gouvernement
n'ait pas une politique plus
volontariste pour arrêter le diesel
responsable d'énormément de pollution on
le sait à cela à ségolène royal a
répondu qu'il ne fallait pas opposer
diesel et pétrole car l'enjeu de demain
est bien celle après pétrole